[Musique]
dans la presse avec vous elle a une
phrase bien sûr bonjour hélène rebonjour
hélène à la une la résistance bien sûr
des ukrainiens toujours confronté aux
bombardements intensifs de l'armée russe
notamment à kharkiv c'est dans l'est de
l'ukraine mieux que n'importe quelle
carte militaire son visage sa peau
mutilé sa chair déchiré recouverte d'un
désinfectant vers prouve la brutalité de
l'invasion russe à la une du times on le
voit ce matin le visage de jelena boli à
shinko 55 ans cette habitante de kharkiv
rencontrer dans un hôpital a décrit au
quotidien britannique comment elle s'est
retrouvée projetée par un cyclone de
verre et d'éclats d'obus contre les murs
de son appartement
touché par un bombardement russe il y a
quatre jours si le visage de jelena boli
tchenko symbolise les souffrances des
ukrainiens et les conséquences de la
stratégie de poutine ses compatriotes
continuent malgré tout de s'enrôler et
de se mobiliser dans un élan de
solidarité et de patriotisme
décuplée par l'invasion selon le figaro
qui voit dans cette résistance
ukrainienne la naissance d'une nation
impayés dans le quotidien célèbre la
combativité face à l'armée russe à
l'image du journal ou krajina mot l'aude
a cité par courrier international qui se
réjouit de voir les informations sur
l'ukraine faire le tour de la terre et
noyer je cite dans la honte la russie
poutinienne certains éditorialistes
allant jusqu'à prédire le pire pour la
fédération de russie à laquelle la
guerre en ukraine je cite toujours va
mettre fin comme la guerre d'afghanistan
a mis fin à lui le kremlin hélène qui a
proposé hier de mettre en place des
couloirs humanitaires à direction de la
russie et la biélorussie il est sans
surprise l'ukraine a rejeté l'offre de
poutine de guardian rapporte que le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky a
répondu en taxant son homologue russe de
cynisme une accusation relier d'ailleurs
par les dessinateurs de presse dont
bretonne moroni pour the times qui
montre des ukrainiens acculé dans cette
couloirs de plus en plus étroits comme
dans le livre de lewis carroll alice au
pays des merveilles
le passage ressemblent en réalité un
piège voire à une impasse allusion aussi
aux critiques adressées aux autorités
britanniques sur leur manque d'humanité
envers les réfugiés du craignant des
couloirs humanitaires version poutine
version blau heures une route qui semble
mener droit aux enfers et dont les
soldats russes seraient les gardiens
dessins publiés par le daily telegraph
vous voyez que je suis un bon gars je
vous donne le choix propose aux
ukrainiens poutine au homard ensanglanté
dans le dessein de brian adcock pour les
indie bundle le président russe se tient
aux côtés de son homologue biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko
lui aussi a du sang sur les mains et
seules les routes qui mènent chez eux
semble sûre contrairement à celle convoi
se dirigeant vers l'ouest vers l'europe
qui est parsemé de civils morts en
tentant de fuir leur pays l'europe qui
fait face on en parlait avec l'hymne à
l'instant aux premières conséquences
économiques de cette guerre la flambée
des prix ou de l'énergie dans des
hypothèses émises line l'a dit
effectivement d'un possible par les
états unis d'un possible embargo sur les
hydrocarbures russes fait planer une
menace pour la reprise en europe selon
les échos qui fait qu'ils font est donc
de l'opposition de l'allemagne
particulièrement
dépendante de l'énergie russe malgré les
réticences allemandes les pressions pour
bannir les importations de gué de gaz et
de pétrole russe augmente et le
quotidien espagnol el mundo indique que
washington cherche désormais à négocier
avec le venezuela pour qu'il augmente sa
production la version écossaise du daily
express qui affiche son soutien avec ce
petit drapeau ukrainien a une envers le
peuple ukrainien site le plaidoyer du
ministre des affaires étrangères
lituanien nous ne pouvons pas payer le
pétrole et le gaz russe avec le sang de
l'ukraine je le cite le prix à payer
pour vaincre poutine titre le tabloïd
avec un autre détail hélène sur sept une
la couleur du bouquet de fleurs que
justin trudeau a offert hier à la reine
d'angleterre
jaune et bleu la gare en ukraine hélène
dans laquelle les femmes paient un lourd
tribut on le sait c'est ce que rappelle
ce matin plusieurs quotidiens à travers
le monde en ce 8 mars journée
internationale
des droits des femmes cette occasion le
quotidien italien la stampa rendent
hommage aux femmes du kenya à toutes les
femmes d'ukraine qu'elle soit
combattante ou mer comme marié à cette
jeune femme dont les images ont fait le
tour du monde photographier en menant
son bébé de 18 mois kirill dans un
hôpital de mario paul où l'enfant est
finalement mort des suites de ses
blessures des femmes comme maria ou des
petites filles comme amelia film est
elle dans les sous sols de kiev en train
de chanter libérer des livres et la
chanson de la reine des neiges une vidéo
qui a été diffusée la semaine dernière
et qui est devenu viral depuis une
journée au féminin dans l'ombre de la
guerre le temps a choisi pour sa une à
lui la photo d'une jeune femme venant
d'accoucher dans un hôpital de kiev sous
le fracas des bombes aujourd'hui les
femmes se trouvent sur le front elles
sont nombreuses sur les routes de l'exil
rappelle le quotidien suisse des
milliers de mères attendent un enfant
qui ne reviendra pas des épouses des
maris dont elles ne seront plus rien
cela se passe en ukraine en russie mais
aussi ailleurs dans le monde qui pense
encore au yémen où al asiri merci
beaucoup à l'âne c'était la revue de
presse